OPEC the club of oil exporters is nearly
60 years old and it's dying dying from a
self-inflicted wound to understand why
we need to go all the way back to 1973
and the Arab oil embargo the
oil-producing countries of the Arab
world decided to use their oil as a
political weapon
this was OPEX Golden Age when it
controlled more than half the world's
oil production and members like Iraq
Iran and Saudi Arabia were nationalizing
their oil fields with the world's thirst
for oil seemingly unquenchable OPEC
demanded higher prices and it got them
in real terms they jumped six-fold
between 1973 and 1980 but the funny
thing about prices is that even for
something as addictive as oil they end
up pushing people to either find more of
the stuff or consume less of it in oils
case they did both by the mid 80s OPEC
controlled less than 30 percent of the
market that had slowed to a crawl
subject tonight on special segments the
oil bashed fast forward to 2008 all
prices hit their highest ever with Brent
crude reaching 146 dollars a barrel
there was no embargo this time just
rampant Chinese demand OPEC made
windfall profits but once again prices
did their work and unleashed a new and
persistent Minister OPEC shale in 2008
the long decline in US oil production
suddenly turned around with output
surging back to levels last seen in the
1970s shale resources are huge they're
relatively quick to develop and have
been getting cheaper so if OPEC tries to
hold oil off the market now that just
lets shale producers potentially step
into
the gap instead of operating under a
cartel
it is now every oil producer for
themselves especially with key OPEC
members Saudi Arabia and Iran facing off
daggers drawn OPEX cozy cartel has
turned into fight